new details are emerging about anhesh's
morning before that fiery car crash left
her in critical condition with severe
burns i see
she was in a crash and i'm just like
floored like oh my gosh i'm praying like
i hope she's okay i hope she's okay
richard glass owned glass hair design in
venice beach and less than an hour
before ann crashed her car into a nearby
house she popped into his shop to buy a
wig we discovered that it was ann
and from there she asked if she could
purchase a red wig that was up top and i
said sure
and as i bring it down i tell her that
it's not cut or styled she said she
didn't care she wanted it anyway
so from there i bring it down i tell her
it's a little bit dusty she says
no worry just sell me some shampoo and
conditioner
it was just
so random so random right now the lapd
is investigating anne for misdemeanor
dui and hit and run they're looking into
what role drugs or alcohol may have
played in the collision
[Applause]
but richard says he didn't notice
anything out of the ordinary about anne
during their encounter she wasn't
speaking in cursive you know i say that
you know if people are impaired you know
they speak in cursive because it's
like you're slurring your words but she
wasn't she was very very cordial very
personable very polite
and um
yeah like the whole
encounter was maybe 10 minutes so
it wasn't
huge
but it was strange all the same and
random the visit also seemed pretty
pleasant check out this selfie richard
snapped with the actress and her new
hair there was
just a coupling of my face she told me
how beautiful i was
and had we worked together and i said no
we hadn't but
i'm available for you you should let me
know sure i took a photo with her and uh
from there
she left and you know what about her day
it was about 20 minutes later that anne
crashed richard found out about the
accident through social media just after
posting that photo i hear my you know my
alert go off and from there i hear or i
see
she was in a crash and i'm just like
floored like oh my gosh i'm praying like
i hope she's okay i hope she's okay i
was just
floored you know and just praying for
her safety you know and everyone
involved everyone involved on monday
andrep told et she's in a coma and has
not regained consciousness since shortly
after the accident
at this time anne is in extremely
critical condition she has a significant
pulmonary injury requiring mechanical
ventilation and burns that require
surgical intervention et has learned
that anne has since been moved to a burn
center in west hills the only message
that i have for anne is her speedy
recovery and
healthy
healthy heart and healthy mind